STEPHANIE WONG: If you
are new to Google Cloud,
it can sometimes
feel like there's
a lot of information
to absorb when
trying to decide
what to use because
of the huge list of
products available.
So this is why we created
a new and simplified page
to help you get started
quickly on Google Cloud
in a handy five-part menu.
Just head to cloud.google.com,
then Getting Started.
Let me give you a quick tour.
For starters, we have three
main essential buckets.
The first is learning how
to sign up for a free trial.
The second is exploring how
to try out different products
via our quick start tutorials.
And the third is, once you
are ready to get started
with Google Cloud, you can
review common developer use
cases or an
enterprise checklist.
When you scroll down
a bit more, for those
who are looking for
a macro-level view
of our entire
suite of offerings,
our amazing team has put
together a helpful color-coded
cheat sheet listing
all our products
and their functions
in four words or less
and their respective features
that you can hover over.
We also have
documented guides that
range from giving you a bird's
eye overview of Google Cloud
or compare Cloud services
with Azure and AWS,
as well as review architecture
references, diagrams,
design patterns,
and best practices
for migrating your
workloads to Google Cloud.
Oh, and here is
my favorite place.
Stay in the know with developer
news and community resources
by checking out the
Developer Center
to join our dev community.
And join the Google
Cloud Innovators Program,
where you can
receive invitations
to hear from Google Cloud
executives and developer
advocates, like myself;
see roadmap presentations;
and a chance for an invitation
to join our new series
of innovator community events.
It's kind of like that
VIP club at Disneyland.
The Dev Center
features highlights
like our new
architecture diagramming
tool, where you can build
architecture diagrams,
see reference architectures, and
even do one-click deployments
directly to Google Cloud.
And now that we got a
high-level overview,
let me walk you through a
couple of different examples.
Let's take a look at some of
the quick start tutorials.
You can browse the catalog
or search for a specific item
to learn more, whether it's
on getting started topics,
like security,
enabling APIs, using
the command-line interface
SDK called gcloud,
creating workflows,
identity and logins,
performing
investigations, et cetera.
There are also more
advanced specific topics,
like databases, storage options,
container VMs, private IPs,
hosting of web apps or services,
machine learning, and more.
When you head to common
developer use cases,
we have a mix of useful
videos and articles organized
under a range of topics
in a friendly interface.
When you are ready to learn
how to build on Google Cloud,
we also have launched an
improved documentation home
page so that you can more easily
find guides, code samples,
tutorials, and API references,
in addition to our architecture
assets.
And there you have it, a
quick walkthrough of our new
getting started resources.
We hope that you check them out.
For now, this is Stephanie Wong.